okay our next speaker is andy no
he's a journalist who serves as
editor-at-large
[Applause]
you're supposed to let me introduce him
first but
he doesn't mind two rounds of applause
um
or more uh so to call him controversial
is maybe somewhat of an understatement
uh he's best known for reporting on
antifa in america
he has written reports on antifa for the
new york post newsweek and many other
publications he came to the attention of
the nation when he was beaten by members
of antifa
on the streets of portland in the summer
of 2019.
i'm happy to say that incident only
increased his determination to report
the truth
and we're grateful for that he's the
author of a recent book titled
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan to
destroy democracy
which is a new york times bestseller
and some of you may recall an incident
from last month when his book made news
headlines
uh winston martial a banjoist for the
band mumford and sons
first publicly endorsed the book
describing noah and has since deleted
tweet as a brave man quote unquote
and then under pressure from a left-wing
cancel culture mob
later recanted his endorsement as
marshall
the banjoist put in a tweet quote for
now please know that i realize
how my endorsements have the potential
to be viewed as approvals
of hatred of divisive behavior
i apologize as this was not at all my
intention so this is the upside down
or bizarro world of cancel culture kind
of on full
display the person who writes about a
group that to use our speaker's words
supports maiming killing and terrorism
is himself accused
of hatred and divisive behavior
unfortunately we've gotten used to this
kind of obsequious and groveling apology
but the more such episodes occur the
more freedom of speech
is curtailed and suppressed these
episodes have the effect
again using our speaker's words of quote
closing curious minds
from independent thought and that's a
problem for us
because free speech is essential to a
free
society well as i said this morning at
hillsdale we're fans of free speech and
we're delighted he could be with us
please welcome andy now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wow
thank you very much for that warm
welcome and thank you to
hillsdale college for the invitation to
speak here i've been looking forward
to this um who here has heard of trigger
warnings
yeah so it's mocked a lot
by people on the right trigger warnings
were popularized
in universities and other left-wing
spaces
basically it's just providing a warning
normally for things that may be
triggering so if it's like reading
a story that has a
triggering language because of so-called
homophobia or racism or anything
is giving a warning and oftentimes
there's
misuse and it's to make students
uh quite snow flaky but there is a place
for it actually
i'm going to give a trigger warning for
this just because
um some of the images and videos i'm
going to show as part of my presentation
uh are graphic and i don't do it to be
sensational or shocking but there's no
way to
report honestly about antifa without
showing
what they actually do which does result
in maimed
bodies and killed people
um so if you
many of you who heard of me probably
first heard of me in 2019 you probably
saw this photo or some variation
of it uh in in the mainstream media
headlines
uh it was this photograph was taken on
the 29th of june
2019 in downtown portland uh
you've probably heard the story i was
recording a
protest from riot by antifa as i've been
doing for many years
and that day in organized
fashion antifa
beach me severely so
the photograph you see mostly all that
liquid stuff on my face but it
that wasn't really what caused the
injuries injuries were the repeated
punches to the face and head
uh i was in the hospital and diagnosed
with a subarachnoid hemorrhage
i don't know what that was doctor had to
explain it to me in layman's terms
that's a brain bleed and you can die
from it
i survived i had about a year of various
medical treatments to address the
deficiencies that resulted from that so
this story has been on on the record
a lot and i want to spend a few moments
just to focus on
other people who were injured on that
same day
a lot of people don't know that in the
course of that riot there were eight
people who were injured
one other person is a man by the name of
john bloom
he was striked on the head was baton by
dante from militant in downtown portland
now keep in mind this was a riot that
was
pre-announced and pre-advertised by
antifa and
the city could not or would not respond
to
stop the violence when i was beaten it
was steps away from the justice center
which is the building that houses the
sheriff's office the central police
precinct so officers inside that
building could probably see me
but i had no help in addition to
john bloom there was adam kelly
he was hit on the head with an overhead
strike by
antiphon member gage halipovsky who was
using a collapsible baton
kelly needed 25 staples to close
the gashes on his head and the beating
was caught on camera you could actually
hear
the sound of the baton hitting his skull
he was lucky to be alive
and here's the body of aaron danielson
in downtown portland last year
after months of rioting in downtown
portland
it escalated to murder an anti-fun
member
shot dead a trump supporter and
in this photograph you can see him on
his shorts he's actually wearing
a patch of the thin blue line which is
showing support for police
police were aware of antifa's plans for
violence in downtown
that day but they were nowhere near to
help the people who were victimized and
one person who was ultimately killed
so i show these images because i want
you and viewers out there to understand
that
antifa is not merely just an idea or
purely theoretical
their ideology and militant tactics
have real-life consequences it's
resulted in destroyed livelihoods in
terms of businesses that have been
continually
vandalized and destroyed over and over
it's resulted in maimings and it
resulted
in death
so who are the antifa
what are they there's a lot of
misinformation out there on both
the left and the right i'll start with
misconceptions
on the right first sometimes you hear
them described as
if they were a single organization
capital a
antifa and that perception
i can understand why exist because of
how organized they are and many of them
travel
to different parts of the country to
engage in criminal activities
but there is no single antifa
on the left you hear them described
as noble anti-fascists who are opposing
racists and the far-right and neo-nazis
what you need to know about antifa is
that they are
a transnational movement that espouses
an extremist communist anarchist
ideology
they merge the worst aspects of both
communism in anarchy
to form a worldview that criminalizes
property ownership wrong think in
produces
endless disorder in crime
they organize themselves via affinity
groups
connected through networks some of the
antifa groups have
anti-fund the name like rose city antifa
which i'm involved in a lawsuit with
because they that militant group in
portland was the one who organized the
violence against me in 2019
but many antifa groups don't have the
word antifungal names as the youth
liberation front
which has cells or chapters across the
united states and they were involved
in months a riot organizing on the west
coast
throughout 2020
they advocate for and carry out acts of
insurgency
against the state they hate america the
most in particular because they
see this country as in their words
imperialistic
in the head of a serpent that spreads
and upholds
fascism around the world they don't just
hate symbols of this country like flags
and
things that represent the rule of law
like courthouses
or law enforcement they really despise
the american philosophy i.e individual
rights
the rule of law and freedom of
expression
an event like this could not be held in
an area where they have significant
control or sway such as portland
antifa seek to make it impossible
literally for conservative
or rightly people to participate in the
public square in urban areas
that's why they beat and rob people
for practicing their first amendment
rights
in left-wing urban centers under the
control of weak
democrats they're able to do it with
impunity
and you don't have to have a
controversial opinion to be
in their crosshairs i'd seen them beat
people
for merely holding the american flag and
just over this past weekend a church in
the
seattle area canceled its event with
tpusa founder charlie cook
after antifa threatened violence
you can think of antifa as somewhat
analogous to worldwide jihadism
in the extreme islamic groups or
individuals inspire
and incite violence against
the infidel their followers may be
formal members of groups
like islamic state but more often
there are simply followers of the
ideology carrying out the call
to violence and like jihadists antifa
honor and celebrate their so-called
martyrs
and despite the long trail of
evidence showing antifa's involvement in
organized criminal activities
which even the fbi director christopher
wray admits
is real this is what you see when you
read the legacy
press headlines here's the associated
press
last year at the height of the riots as
trump
blames antifa protest records show scant
other evidence new york times
despite despite claims by president
trump
and attorney general william p barr
there's
scant evidence that loosely organized
anti-fascist a significant player in
protest
so journalists who have the benefit of a
corporate media backing
with huge resources came to these
conclusions
myself just as an independent journalist
this is what i was what i was able to
find
so this is amelia shem roberts
she a male to female transsexual
was arrested in may 2020
in portland as the george floyd
blm's bio riots broke out
she was charged with felony arson felony
rioting felony criminal mischief
in two counts of conspiracy to commit a
class a felony
now i didn't see this reported in the
press but i actually looked up her court
records
and this is what the criminal complaint
says
quote when her roommates
asked how shinrowicz started the fires
chamrowicz
responded by saying that it is not a
conversation
for facebook messenger and that she will
be home soon
a subsequent in-person conversation
occurred and the roommates reported
that chambrowitz stated she started the
fire
using a molotov cocktail and she is part
of antifa
cherowitz was reported to be extremely
excited
about being labeled a terrorist and was
very animated about her hopes
that police officers would be killed and
injured by the riots
she also stated that she would be going
out on another mission
and the goal would be to set another
fire end quote
that wasn't reported in the local
national press
and her charges were dropped by the
district attorney
here's another one ryan howe
another male-to-female transsexual
this person she's from rochester new
york she was
federally charged in september 2020 with
inciting
or organizing a riot howe shared a
homemade ied recipe
and posted about arson attacks on her
social media
i actually was able to find her account
which is under a pseudonym
and this was her profile photo you won't
see this in the headlines
here's another one brittany austin
another male to female transsexual she
also goes by the name samaya dawud she's
a convert to islam
she was arrested had a violent protest
in phoenix arizona
last year at the time of her arrest she
was carrying
a ar-15 she was charged with felony
first degree hindering prosecution
felony right unlawful assembly assisting
a criminal street gang
some of the local reporting mentioned
her as being part of a
protest group racial protest group none
of them
mentioned what you see on the photo on
the right which is what i was able to
find on her social media
back to portland jared de ferrari
another male to female transsexual this
person
came all the way to portland from
sunrise florida
they also go by the name sophie she was
indicted on one count of felony riot
three counts of felony first degree
criminal mischief
according to court documents she
destroyed
property at saint andre bessette
catholic church in downtown portland
in this video of it this is a catholic
church that provides
charity outreach to homeless people in
portland which is a very
large and vulnerable population i'll
show you the video
which allegedly shows dave ferrari at
that antifa right
you can see people who have press
mockings walk right on by
and don't photograph or record this
wanton act of violence
against the church that provides
services to the homeless
and he a contemporary phenomenon but
they do take their name
misses and symbols from an older
organization
the anti-fascist accion or afa
as you can probably tell from the names
german the
original afa was founded
in 1932 as a violent paramilitary of the
german communist party
they were involved in extremely violent
political street ball brawls
and systematically work to undermine the
social democratic government of the
weimar republic this was just shortly
before
world war ii antifa won't admit it today
but their forebears
actually paved the way for the rise of
hitchler by creating a climate
of extreme political polarization and
instability
after world war ii the quantum chord
anti-far
ideology of the communists was absorbed
into the official state ideology of east
germany
in the name of so-called anti-fascism
the east
german regime built the stasi
which was the ministry for state
security where citizens
were monitored and spied on through a
vast
asper apparatus of informants
who infiltrated all aspects of life in
civil society
the berlin wall built to stop
its own citizens from fleeing the
tyranny of the east
was called the anti-fascist defense
barrier officially by germany a lot of
people
don't know that historically
and today and he quote unquote
anti-fascism or antifa
have nothing to do with actually
opposing fascism
it is a cover for an explicitly far-left
communist agenda most mainstream lesbian
people
are ignorant to this this is why you
have
fools on cnn describing antifa
as comparable to american soldiers
liberating europe of fascism
in the same fashion black lives matter
has
nothing to do with racial justice and
it's just a rebranded version
of black revolutionary marxism seen in
america
decades ago
antifa's far left theories and ideology
was able to slip
in america through academics
herbert marcusa and other european
marxist
intellectuals fled europe in the last
century
and found a home in academic
institutions
so things like critical theory and from
that
critical race theory trans ideology
intersectionality
all that was born in america's academic
institutions
and you can see the effects of it today
and hollowing out
pretty much everything that it touches
discussing antifa's origins and their
ideology
can be complicated to the layman there's
a lot of history there there's a lot of
terms and concepts antifa would rather
we just take them at their word that
they are simply
anti-fascist but if listening to
what they say and write is too
complicated
how about we just look at what they do
when they're given the opportunity
this close-up is one of the barrier
checkpoints in seattle's capitol hill
autonomous zone last year
to recap that was when for three weeks
during the summer the city
allowed groups of armed left-wing
militants to seize
six blocks of city property in an area
that is densely populated near downtown
now seattle is the biggest city in the
pacific northwest
in america we're not talking about a
failed state
like libya or somalia or somewhere else
this is america the militants
declared themselves sovereign from the
u.s you can see one of the signs here
on the right it says you are now leaving
the usa
so i actually went under cover there i
wanted to see with my own eyes is this
can this really be happening because
from what i was reading in the headlines
it was this was just a wonderful street
party this was pr
protest industry for racial justice when
i saw there they had
actual multiple checkpoints all around
those six blocks this was one of the
checkpoints
and they were manned by people who were
armed with rifles and pistols
and police were chased out
it's chas as it was known the capitol
hill autonomous zone was
praised by the press it was praised by
seattle city council
and even the seattle mayor in infamously
went on cnn to say that this could
become a summer of love
but what happened in there was a zone
of terror and death in those three weeks
there were
six shootings austin attempts
an attempted rape into homicides
far zone established to be
a refuge for black people it had a 100
percent
black victim shooting and homicide rate
one of the victims who was killed was a
16 year old teen
he was shot he was shot dead by the chas
security
they mistook him for being a white
supremacist when he was in the car
they shot dozens of rounds into the
vehicle
and the one that likely killed him was
the one that went through the windshield
i looked at the photographs and videos
of the car
it was soaked with blood on the inside
and the evidence was destroyed by the
occupants of chaz
so to to this day police still don't
know
who killed that 16 year old
it wasn't just chaz of course this is a
statue
former statue in downtown portland's elk
it was quite beloved by the city and its
citizens
it was set on fire and destroyed it was
one of eight statues
that were destroyed in portland along
with the statues of george washington
abraham and roosevelt
for more than 120 days night after night
antifa
rioted in portland minneapolis is
probably what people think of
when they think of where the worst
rioting happens because
actual full neighborhoods were torched
to the ground
in portland we had to sustain violence
from months on end
that lasts continuously from 120 days
to which now it's still going on but
it's happening
maybe four or five times a week instead
of every night that's the
improvement we have in the city so
portland is my hometown and i
was living and working there last year
and seeing with my own eyes what was
happening
to my city in the course of writing my
book on mass
what i was seeing every night was
organized mobs a rioters
setting fires to buildings that were
occupied by people
they came armed with weapons
really brutal but simple weapons
like knives taped to the ends of
umbrellas
molotov cocktails other homiira
ieds small knives
rocks lasers used to damage the eyes of
their opponents in law enforcement
we hear a lot about what happened on the
6th of january in dc
all the actions of that day and more
occurred for months on end in portland
here's some undercover video that i
recorded last year
so a barrier was erected to protect the
federal courthouse
much like what we see in front of the
capitol
today and there were thousands of people
who came
night after night to try to burn that
building down
they came with power tools as you see
here to cut into the fence
when that was unsuccessful they laid her
attached ropes
around strategic parts of the fence and
used hundreds of people
to break it apart which was successful
if you read the headlines at that time
they were reckoning
what the mayor the governor the two
senators and others were saying in
oregon which
is that these were protesters responding
to trump's gestapo secret police
that were disappearing people
those comments incited more violence
and allowed it to continue night after
night after night
here's an attack where a mass militant
threw a molotov cocktail at a group of
law enforcement
the individual here after more than six
months of an investigation
has been arrested and charged he
actually came to portland all the way
from minneapolis
allegedly specifically for the purpose
of writing
96 people have been federally charged
around half have had their cases
dismissed
the remaining have mostly had deferred
resolution deals
which means that their cases are dropped
once they complete some brief volunteer
work
at the local level we had more than a
thousand
arrests related to the months and months
of rioting last year
with our progressive district attorney
he dropped the cases of more than 90
percent of them
this is justice in portland
for reporting on auntie cell's violent
extremism
i was beaten as you know and have been
continually subjected to death threats
antifa have showed up to my home to try
to break in
they write things like that around the
city they've written my address
as well in public i have more than two
dozen
reports with the portland police
no one's ever been arrested
this is michael rhino he's the portland
antifa member who shot dead
aaron danielson in downtown last year
he had run-ins with law enforcement on
three
occasions shortly before going on his
mission to kill
the photo on the right that was him
getting arrested at a riot the month
prior
you see that gun on the ground that was
his it was illegally possessed
he was charged and all those charges
were dropped
and then he went on to kill
portland's not really in the headlines
that much anymore
but the violence is continuing
just two weeks ago antifa again set to
portland police union hall on fire the
photo
on the left is some of the damage you
see from that
when derek shoving was found to be
guilty on all the charges
antifun downtown portland set buildings
on fire
i read you one of the tweets from the
official account of portland police
which were giving live updates
this fire is near an occupied building
and a propane tank
and another riot they went on to destroy
a children's charity
and they also smashed up another church
what can be done well my role as a
journalist is more so
to describe and inform people what's
happening rather than to give
solutions so this part of the speech is
probably the most
challenging for me to write
and depressing i think i do think cities
like portland seattle and minneapolis
and others are
possibly beyond saving there's a
critical
mass of support for far left extremism
masquerading as racial justice in those
areas
notice i said critical mass not a
majority you don't have to have a
majority of people
supporting what's happening you just
have to have enough and there's enough
of it there
and they vote for the politicians that
enable it
through violence antifa have driven out
any meaningful opposition in urban
liberal areas
this is a fight that liberals in the
moderate left have to take on themselves
but if 2020 was any indication
that's not something they're willing to
do in fact they're probably more likely
to join in on the protests and volunteer
themselves
to stand in between the rioters and
police
i predict further civilizational and
cultural decline in the us
as the critical theorists continue their
successful efforts
at hollowing out every institution they
touch
academe journalism entertainment
government military
through the years we've witnessed how
far left extremists like
bill eyers bernardine dorn
angela davis and assassin shakur have
been
successfully rebranded into racial
justice activists
in academics rather than communist
terrorists involving bombings
shootings and murders
similarly papers are record and
politicians would have you believe
that antifa are just fighting neo-nazis
i recently spoke on record about my
decision to
flee the united states this has
pained me a lot because my family found
asylum here as refugees fleeing
communist
vietnam both my parents were sent to
prison camp
in the 1970s
i'm continuing my reporting from abroad
resigned to belief that my home city is
dying
and that the disease killing it
will continue to spread i'm not sure
what the antidote
is but i hope conferences like this
will help inform the public about
what to look for before it's too late
where you live
thank you
thank you mr no we now have time for
some q a
if you have a question please make your
way to a microphone
hi hi mr no thank you for your
comments and you're a very brave man
my question has to do with um
we often hear and i was wondering if you
could tell us the truth
of whether people with money aka george
soros and things like that
i always hear that they're involved in
our financing behind the scenes do you
know
if that is for sure true or if they are
just taking advantage of circumstances
so that's the question that i uh when i
was writing my book
uh thought to announcer i wanted to find
out where the money is coming from
that's a question that i
had been asked most frequently over the
past couple of years and it was
something i
was curious about myself and
the answer is i found no evidence that
there's
that there are any big shadowy
millionaire billionaire
billionaire figures funding the actual
militant
antifa violence on the streets
the money that they do get which is
significant actually is done
pretty much out in the open they create
campaigns
on gofundme to raise bail money
in legal funds they establish ad hoc
front groups to gather those funds and
to launder it to their causes
they also create accounts on
cash app venmo or paypal these are some
of the
apps and sites where you can donate
money
small amounts and amounts added up to
hundreds of thousands in the case of
portland the
portland bail fund which was one of
these anti-for-front groups raising
money
for all the right was arrested raised
more than 1.3 million dollars
in minneapolis tens of millions of
dollars was raised
with in part with the help of our
current vice president
for accused rioters in minneapolis as
well as
those accused of murder and other
heinous crimes
so
you know f is to think that you could
topple
the one funding source to cut them off
it's not simple like that
um big tech has not been
putting much effort into shutting down
these accounts and pages
because it's it's masked in a way right
like with the group name that sounds as
innocuous as the portland
defense fund you wouldn't think that
these are far left extremists who are
raising money for
people charged with felony assault
and arson and other crimes
question to the speaker's left hi i live
in the greater seattle area and we
watched
on tv all asked the riots it happened
my question is if you pull off the masks
of these people
who are they great question so
uh if people follow me on my twitter
one of the projects i've been doing for
almost a year now is
in the portland area because there's
been so many arrests in portland i will
actually do the public records request
to get the booking photos
the names and charges and you'll see
that there is really no one type of
antifa
there are a couple of things that
generally you can say they
lean young you have some people who are
young as
15 years old getting arrested to those
in
their early 30s slightly more men than
women involved
disproportionately people who identify
as transgender
and at some point i would like to write
on this more but i
i believe it's because the transgender
ideology is political ideology that's
very radical
so that's why you're seeing an
over-representation in those
involved in far-left activities
some of them are people in very white
collar jobs there's been registered
nurses
and attorneys who have been arrested one
of the staffers
for the speaker of the house for the
state of oregon was arrested at a riot
um there's of many many students of
course and even
faculty in academes who's been arrested
out these riots
um and uh and another thing is that many
of them are
homeless or otherwise
very vulnerable populations of people
and
um i read about in my book that i
there's a sympathy i feel for many of
them because
these are people who
they want community and this antifa
extremist
movement ideology gives them that
community it gives them meaning and
purpose it does a lot of things of like
what trade
religion traditionally would do but it
also leads them down a path
towards violence and some of them get
seriously injured
in the process of them trying to fight
police or assault
people and then they're just kind of
discarded
um it's a very wicked and destructive
movement ideology and
but i'm not sure what it will take for
the public
to wake up and realize this threat to
america that comes from this group i
think
sometimes they usually dismiss as weak
soy boys
and soy girls on the street who don't
know what they're doing that's partially
true but you don't have to be strong
to stab somebody you don't have to be
strong to have a pistol
in your pocket and shoot somebody dead
so
the right does underestimate antifa
question to the speakers right yes
first thank you for the courage that
you've shown
secondly i just read
that the mayor of portland is asking
people to turn
antifa people in and i wondered what
your response to that would be
and another quick question what is the
relationship
between black lives matter and antifa
portland mayor ted wheeler is serving
his second term he was elected at the
beginning or he came into office at the
beginning of 2017 and it was under his
watch the antifa grew to become
the existential threat that it is today
to portland for
going back several years now he gave
them the legitimacy to do what they do
and he restricted and tied
the ability to for police to respond
because he's also the
police commissioner he says the dual
role
and he did all that because of his
blind hatred of trump which he made very
very clear
which is not unique to him many democrat
elected officials
hate trump more than they love their own
communities and their
fellow citizens with him doing the 180
now
it's too little too late i mean he was
instrumental last year
in pushing for the police department to
be
defunded it was under his leadership
that the gun violence reduction team in
portland police was abolished
and now we have record high numbers of
shootings and homicides
and so he's pleading with the public
to essentially help police with some of
their investigations
yet the city will offer you no help if
in the course of you
trying to photograph suspicious
individuals in your neighborhood you get
assaulted or a rock thrown through your
window as
happened a few days ago will anybody
come to protect you the city certainly
won't
so too little too late i say
regarding black lives matter
in my writings i usually link blm and
antifa i describe them really as a
single entity
but what people should know is they are
different in their ultimate goals
um antifa as i said is anarchist
communist whereas
blm is just straight communist
and so these differences
are meaningful and ultimately if they
were to be successful
in their destruction of america they
would it would lead to
inviting one group or the other will win
but for now they work together
in the form of antifa providing security
out these blm demonstrations that also
turn into riots
what i was seeing in portland and other
cities last year with the mass
looting is that the antifa would
be the first to break the windows to
breach the
doors or windows of the building and
then
sort of unleash the opportunists
to loot and destroy businesses and then
once that's done
they'll just go in and start a fire and
destroy what's left
so the relationship is
mutually beneficial because of the
shared
hatred of the united states i think it's
you can tell the difference between
somebody who is
a critic versus somebody who's an enemy
if you listen
to what blm activists and what antifa
say obviously they fall
in the latter question to the speaker's
left
thank you andy for being here today my
question
is there are also international groups
that are similar and what are the
numbers
uh internationally and domestically that
fall into these
this type of organization yeah
so this is a question that really is
almost impossible to answer in that it's
the same way to ask like
how many muslim extremists are there in
the world
it's like the delineations is often not
clear
you don't have to be a card-carrying
member um
you don't have to have trained in syria
or iraq with is to actually be a member
so
who actually fits that i think there's
an issue
similar issue with anti-phone you're
trying to find out how many members they
are
you have to look at it if you want to
know numbers you have to look at it more
maybe group by group like rose city
antifa
which has uh from my estimates
less than 100 people who are actually
involved
relatively their numbers are actually
small but
they're able to do so much damage
because
they have a lot of wider support
in the mainstream left i mean you can
look at our
papers of record the commentaries that
they print and those who go on
broadcast television to excuse
far left political violence to argue
that
destruction and looting in austin is not
actually violence or that it's justified
in the name of racial justice
so it's it's this tacit
support from the wider life that gives
them the ability to do what they do
you know you can in in conservative
areas where there are
elected politicians who are responsible
and recognize the
the threat that antifa opposed to the
public they don't allow
them to build the networks to
destabilize
the city but when you're in an area like
portland or seattle or
the bay area or philadelphia
there's wide support for it
question to the speakers right the
threat of uh
violence or death is is real
and uh two things one you mentioned
about
seattle and portland being pretty much
done
i was in indianapolis recently and i was
having a talk with a
police officer and he said we are told
to stand down
uh arson is not a crime basically i mean
it's not to be prosecuted
uh only if it is uh a
human uh a human's life is at stake
that's number one and
number two one of your comm one of your
comment about
the stand down orders from mayors and
chiefs of police
but uh also you had kind of brought it
up
it's not just a little bit of antifa
and a huge majority of people against
antifa
there's a huge middle section a big
middle section of citizens that are
going
it's just for racial justice and it's
peaceful protests
you had made some comments i'd love to
hear more comments about
this middle section of people
uh i think they need to get active with
their
elected representatives like strongly
and say hey no
this is not going to be in our city
i said earlier in the speech that this
at least in urban left-wing areas this
is really a fight for
liberals and the moderate left
but even in the rare instances where
they've tried to voice their opposition
for example
in seattle in in the area of the the
former so-called chaz there has
continued to be
weekly violence there by antifa and
a association of business owners and
residents in the area
wrote a letter to the mayor asking for
a restoration of law and order and the
response from antifa was
to release the personal information of
every person who signed that letter
that has resulted in
the public being very very afraid to
speak out
so you know antifa
they don't just do the street
hooliganism they it's
threat threats and intimidation and
harassment
and for the average working person
that's just not the type of they can't
deal with that type of onslaught
and
yeah i wish that uh politicians like
mayor wheeler and
and others had have woken up to this
threat um
but they they chose to empower it and
it's not really them who will suffer i
mean wheelers
from a very wealthy background he will
retire and have a good life it's the
people in portland who don't have the
money to leave
i'm very privileged that i got my
resources together
to to leave as painful and difficult as
not spin
that's uh the people stuck in the cities
who have to deal
with the political consequences question
to the speaker's left
i'd like to say first of all thank you
again for your courage and boldness i'd
like to pray for
god's protection and healing for you
physically and emotionally it must be
like we can't imagine what you've been
through
but my question has to do with the
history of non-violent
resistance to evil in our country
you know going back to the 50s and 60s
dr martin luther king jr
and that whole tradition of non-violence
are there no churches are there no
christians
are there no is there no one left in
this country
who is inspired by dr king
to uh to stand between
this evil and those that it seeks to
destroy
i think the heroes of the past that are
lauded now
by the current left the figures that
they pick
tells us a lot they don't uphold
the memory and legacy of martin luther
king jr
they celebrate people like assata shakur
a wanted felon an enemy of america who
fled to cuba
after her involvement in killing the
state trooper in new jersey
they uphold malcolm x they uphold black
panthers
they reject the tradition of non-violent
civil
disobedience because they see how
effective
threats and violence actually are i mean
in my view they held the entire country
under threat of mass violence in death
and destruction
if they didn't get the outcome in the
trial that they wanted
regarding chauvin um
again this is this transformation in the
left has been happening
slowly uh since the since the last
um century started in academe if you go
back to 2015 i
was kind of troubled that a lot of the
people on the right
dismissed the campus rage stuff
as just kind of a joke about the
screaming and the crying and the
extremism on campuses
is something to be mocked and it's just
going to go away well the students went
on to graduate they work in an
administration now they go on to
be on city councils they run for
government
and you can see the drastic effect has
had on culture and politics in just
five years that's going to continue
um i don't think that
the issues we're facing now are going to
go away with a different administration
i mean even with the previous
administration
there wasn't really much that trump
could do to counter
what has happened in in journalism
in in local governments in in academe
um i i just feel like with the the
current administration that process of
decline is just sped up but it is going
to happen regardless
we have time for one final question
oh great um andy big fan
of yours i've been following you for
several years and god bless your heart
for doing such great work
so my question is a little different and
i guess i'm looking for some optimism
here
i really need it um
in your work all over the country and
talking to people
all over the place i sort of personally
get a sense that there are all these
little militias out there forming
to take our country back do you ever
hear
anything about that of course i'm from
the south so i might hear things
differently than other people do
we're not going to go down softly let me
tell you that
but but seriously do you ever hear any
undercurrent of discontent
on with the conservatives that are ready
to
put up or shut up um
[Music]
i think we saw an intent on that in some
form at least
possibly you could argue that on the 6th
of january and
that's not something i think that the
right
should embrace um
i don't think the response to left-wing
political violence left-wing extremism
is to
take up arms and to fight them on the
streets
if you look at the history of the
violent republic
part of the conditions that led to
the populist
electing or excuse me welcoming
in hitler was that
there was a lot of back and forth to
political violence involving
paramilitaries of not just the
communists but the nazis how the
imperial military the social democrats
were in paramilitaries they were taken
to the streets they were fighting each
other they were
disrupting each other's events their
assassinations and encounter
assassinations
i
um i'm not sure what this you know
possible
solutions can be i think that that
that's left to
to other thinkers i'm just here to tell
my
reporting on antifa i think but my
impulse though is to say that i think
you
can work through the system at least
locally to
to save your communities from this rock
that is affecting
primarily liberal urban areas um
but i i would be very concerned with
anybody advocating for
an escalation
we've had a lot of people die in
political violence in just the past year
and a half and
certainly i don't hope for any more of
that to happen
[Applause]
you